hey guys stop what you're doing right
now go to your DVR please please please
write this down send yourself in a note
put it in your phone you got your phone
in your hand and just set an alarm jun
7th on travel channel my show bert the
conqueror premieres for its third season
i am extremely proud of this product I
worked really hard I spent the majority
of my summer on it busting my ass and
and I wanted everyone to watch it and I
want you to watch it more importantly I
want you to like it and I want you to
share with your friends and I want you
to talk about it to other people so the
only way you can do that is by watching
it the only way you're going to watch it
is if you set a reminder set a reminder
set your DVR go look on your DVR the
next to be like oh that's right Bert I
gotta get this [ __ ] show down it's on
travel channel go to travel channel
tomorrow to go to it tonight and take a
look at all the fantastic programming we
have out for you there it's amazing Josh
gates is show expedition unknown booze
traveler hotel impossible the list goes
on and so that's what I want to share
with you today's podcast oh I have tour
dates [ __ ] i have tour dates I am I am
doing should have time this out a little
better I'm in helium comedy club in st.
Louis this week the 26 27 and 28th of
may also be there the 25th I'm in
schaumburg illinois the 9th through 11th
of june flappers Burbank come out local
flappers Burbank on june seventeenth and
eighteenth orlando improv i am back in
o-town the 24th 25th 26th I've got a
showtime special coming out soon I know
the exact air day to that I think that's
everything I have I obviously have
shirts and books Bert Bert Bert calm my
wife would like to speak
to you yes like to say that today's
episode is brought to you by helix sleep
you know night after night to people lay
in the same bed when it comes time to
buy a new mattress only one of them gets
their way no that's not totally true
well I think sometimes I thought you
said well yeah only one person gives
away i mean the mattress were sleeping
on is a little hard for you yeah I
didn't get to pick I didn't get to pick
the firmness cuz you wanted firmer and
so I had to put a featherbed on it
exactly see only one person got their
way I thought I was thinking only one
person got to sleep in it and I was like
sometimes people share Paris sometimes
only Weber's and sleeps a nut bread cuz
you're on the road sometimes oh and when
I am here I'm snoring and you're there
you go there you go and the mom cave
okay so uh only one person gets their
way until now introducing helix sleep
where you can buy a mattress online
customized for both of you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands go to
helix sleep calm and answer a few simple
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile used to build you the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever sleep
on what kind of like that it's like when
you build your own car when your car
shopping totally that would be kind of
fun right so your mattress arrives in
about a week and the shipping is a
hundred percent free and for couples he
likes customizes each side of the
mattress personalized to suit oh wait a
minute they customize each side of the
mattress that means that you could have
a softer side and I could have a firmer
side I'd like that that's actually
awesome I'd like that heelys customers
report a thirty percent improvement in
overall sleep quality and you have a
hundred Knights to try it out and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free nights they let you sleep in it for
three months I know right you know that
things going back with like bedbugs or
something chiggers lots of a baby
donziger's and i get is yelling doesn't
the [ __ ] you sleepy usually be in your
mattress in the woods but what do they
do with them when they get them back
they football upside down
highly doubt that anyway you have a
hundred nice to try it and if you don't
love it they pick it up for free and you
get a hundred percent refund I like that
let's just buy one hahaha santa bag
let's just keep doing that every three
months a little more firm I am I was
dissolved you're talking to Cinderella
over here it is really kind of cool down
beauties this is a great thing that you
could like have half the mattress firm
and half the mattress off it's like it
that's awesome yeah I mean it's a
problem with something like a sleep
number bed is I would forget my number
in this way there's no number you just
gonna it's the same I like that so
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
so go to helix sleep calm / Burt and get
fifty dollars off your order that's
helix sleep h-e-l-l-o elex complex oh oh
there's talk about beds make it alright
is that all you want to share yeah I
think that's it okay and buy buy a
t-shirt Bert Bert Bert calm Burt casscom
yeah our p.o box is 707 north hollywood
california said the streets 9 160 3 10 4
and you don't put 10 uh hey guys I'm
gonna be trying something new coming up
this next couple weeks the vlog has been
a blast but it's been really difficult
I'm not really good at giving notes and
I'm not really good at the full editing
I'm gonna try something new so get ready
for it I think it's gonna come out I'm
gonna do my first one maybe next week or
the week after that but it should be fun
it should be cool should be different
and I think you guys will like it so so
yeah I don't won't tell you exactly what
it is yet in case I don't do it at all
but today's podcast was a fantastic
podcast it was so fun
and I'm releasing this today because his
album drops Friday uh he is a comic he's
been he worked at the store he's been at
the store his whole career I've known
him for a long time I've known of him
longer than I've known him but he's one
of those guys that that is synonymous
with with with just good times that the
story's got a podcast with Kevin Christy
called occasionally awesome I think
that's what it's called it's on all
things commonly occasionally awesome got
him good and his new album night his
name's Nick Yusuf let me get that out
right now just so they are you I know
you already know who it is I don't want
to like load up with all this info and
you're like wait who the [ __ ] are we
talking about he's got a new album
coming out this Friday you can pre-order
it today guys I say this to all the
naysayers out there that are stuck in a
time capsule that don't believe in the
power of podcasting but that is the
future Nick Yousef can text me and say
hey man do you mind if I do your podcast
to promote my my my I'm I saw my album
on iTunes and then you guys can go
straight to iTunes and download it and
get them at the top of the charts and
there is no traditional media used to
promote it I love that so please by all
means go to iTunes subscribe to his
podcast so by his new album 1982 he is
absolutely hilarious and we have a
fantastic conversation about everything
I won't spoil it for you I'll let you
listen to it have a great [ __ ] week
everybody be safe this weekend I will be
in st. Louis all weekend ladies and
gentlemen today's guest oh I should also
tell you I have two gangsters podcasts
after this I'm killing with podcasts and
the little teaser Ron White and Harley
Morenstein from Epic Meal Time yeah but
right now right now and I guarantee you
if you love the Danish Antonio one
you're gonna love this one ladies and
gentlemen Nick Yousef
this thing
now on all things comedy yeah you gotta
do it I'd love to yeah um he's talking
about Mike talking into the mic all
right that is perfect um yeah so I I was
looking through your instagrams today
and I was like yeah [ __ ] man I want to
be artistic sweet what's the new album
about or is it songs no it's comedy it
said songs on and I was like did he
change his [ __ ] entire act yeah I
know laying didn't stand up and I was
like Moses mother [ __ ] I mean I want
to release an album so bad I feel like I
feel like it's what you know what
happens though is you get you go I'm
gonna do an album and you get all
excited and you're like I'm gonna tell
me to fill I'm gonna tape it in DC i'll
do i'll do 4 shows six shows yeah put
the best album but bananas tracks
together yeah and then you're like okay
then you tell your agents managers and
they're like well let's wait around to
see if anyone wants to do a special
right and you get sidetracked and then
you lose materials you get bored of it
exactly let's tell your album came out
and I was like [ __ ] man i'm jealous yeah
so when did you where did you film it i
did it at the punchline San Francisco
where you from I'm from LA I want to
grow up in LA eleven people that are
from here are you grew up in LA yeah
what's Yousef is that it's Middle
Eastern it's Lebanese Lebanese yeah does
that mean you in Tripoli flight fight
all the time no he's our media and I
just tell them that mine mine's better
than his cuz there's no Lebanese out
here there's a ton of Armenians and
people are always like how these aren't
meeting guys in there Pam dough is Jude
so he gets the front of it and Armenian
guys hang out at our like on our street
you'll see them all the time yeah just
hanging out having coffee they just sit
smoke cigarettes have coffee all day all
day yeah and I'm always wondering what
the [ __ ] they're up to no one knows it's
like they just like chill all day and
then they are the nicest possible cars
so immediate you're like there's a mafia
situation how do they all have great
cars I don't know that drives me nuts
like I feel like I'm not good with my
money yeah so I feel like I if anyone's
gonna have an expensive car would be me
I'd be like I'll just buy expensive car
I can't afford one and I look at these
guys do bro drivers are pick me up in a
in twenty thousand dollar Mercedes yeah
you're like it's just like an AMG I got
a chronic saying they go what kind of
car is this means i go it's uh dot your
back seat reclines it's like any like we
heats up and like and as a jacuzzi in
the trunk oh [ __ ] yeah so did so did you
start did you twas a punchline one of
your home clubs was the first call that
ever worked me on the road like I screw
up in la started comedy in LA so it was
like that like I know people I was like
why would you do that or what the [ __ ] I
just laid low for a few years and didn't
showcase at any of the clubs there
anyway but that's like I'm even having a
problem with with doing stand-up in the
city now because you do stand-up and
everyone at Comedy Central's there yeah
[ __ ] there's producers there the even
like the store i feels like more of a
showcase club these days yeah totally is
truly bizarre yeah but when I started
there like I I did the open mics and all
that stuff and just stayed away from the
club's until I had some material and I
could you know feel confident to
showcase for anything and then I got
into the store back when it was
practically closed you know no one went
there for any reasonable yours us that's
03 late summer of us trees when I got
hired as an employee really and I worked
like the door in the lot and answer the
phones every morning and all that [ __ ]
but it was so dead back then that like
the phone ship was nine to one from 9-11
I was sleeping really wasn't even
disturbed by a phone call roll out of
bed and be like I was basically like
taking a break to Reese leaf again and I
get there I get like a newspaper from
starbucks and a coffee that I wouldn't
touch until i woke up at eleven and i
wake up there's no internet or cable so
i'd watch the view every morning and
like all my children those the only
thing I there was no internet no money
for a computer so I just SAT there and
watched that and no one would call till
noon and when they would they'd be like
are there shows tonight like it wasn't
even like we got to come see are you
guys open like ever you know oh yeah
shows are at nine and you'd have to
struggle to find a credit to give really
anyone on the line whose headline there
at the time is it it's I mean the only
name I remember
back then was like Rogan that was the
only person you were to fall out Yahweh
away before this was when he was on fear
factor and you could be from fear factor
Joe rotors and [ __ ] yeah who else you
got were like mrs. visit like you don't
no clear way through uh you but you'd
always be like Brian Holtzman cuz he's
like a legend dude I heard I heard the
other night someone told me that Brian
Holton rent one on stage and like
everyone ran in to go watch him oh yeah
he's he's just he's unpredictable and
like angry and crazy like he's just the
best please calm down a lot of these be
used to be you just never know what was
gonna happen so you'd have to go in
there really cuz it wouldn't be you
would want to miss the possible set we
like unloads on a crowd walks the room
because he would just lose his mind over
like any issue any any topic really yeah
he's just like he's just super intense
and like wild and angry and funny but
like funny you look at he's a guy that
there's like he's like there's legends
about him yeah like stories where he
would like flip out and walk the room
and like you you just make racial jokes
that would people would get sensitive
about and he'd flip out and get angry
you getting angry kind of thing storm
off stage screaming in people's faces
and he's like a big menacing birdies
like an airplane mechanic yeah and you
see like I but he worked as a parking
enforcement officer for a while we're
here like what may be the last person
you want to run into getting a tickin or
minus D a little parking if a [ __ ] you
pound the [ __ ] ticket you gave me and
then he would go to [ __ ] you you know
sorry aw no anything you need to get
that dude out of your face yeah he was
there a lot um I just like Maz Jobrani
was there Sebastian before he was like
Sebastian he looks like another dude
there i was telling someone when i met
Sebastien was um do you ever go to those
uh those soft ball home run derby games
we play no we do me Ernst oh I I used to
hear about them as Vera's friends allows
guys so they would mention them I've
never invited oh I just most just
friends with Steve Byrne yeah I don't
know anyone else yeah it seems like you
should come hang out get to know
everyone yeah
and I was like okay so he's always the
guy who like brings p he's very likable
Toby buddies hang out you know so funny
he steve is a complex individual yeah
cuz there's another side to see where if
he decides he hates you you're like no
turning that around I've seen him do
that we're going to just decided like
this person and it all [ __ ] it's like
an it's like a Holocaust and so and so
so we started doing that home run derby
in the first day I got there early I
don't know anyone and I go over the
thing I see Sebastian I don't know I
don't even know that he's a comic like I
just and the way he's acting I'm like
this guy does not do stand-up comedy
like yeah he's super serious he's
putting on knee high socks elbow pads
he's lacing up high top cleats with like
yeah / loafers at the same time and he
had like he had those like the slides at
black dudes wear with socks and a kid he
had his warm-up outfit getting ready for
his game outfit that's matching gloves
and like a visor with his hair done up
putting on sunscreen and I'm just
looking at him like I go you're drinking
a beer and you're like what's this guy's
problem I was who I was just telling
this to I was i think i was wearing i'm
being nine [ __ ] around i think i
might have been wearing flip-flops yeah
and i was just like yeah yeah and I'm
looking at him as Steve shows up and
he's like birthday Sebastian and I was
like hey how you doing I said what do
you do and he goes I'm a comedian and I
went really and I was like that is your
teen is so serious like and then he got
up and he was just like him and Bret
Ernst would swing and cursed [ __ ] man
like as they'd swing Brett would swing
and go get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
Booya take that and I literally was like
these are the most interesting group of
guys I've ever met yeah Rena ZZ was like
a college football star right and [ __ ] I
just literally sat in the outfield and I
was like well then I'd played I got
recruited to play college baseball so I
was like I'm out I was actually really
good yeah so immediately like there lay
the record was like one or two home runs
and then I get up and hit
no 15 the first time and they were like
who the [ __ ] is this guy yeah and I was
like he's invited every Sunday yes yeah
but it was uh he was really interested I
mean I don't know what was it was early
like bitterness at the store like do
people hate each other not always seems
like I got a fraternity vibe I was there
probably at the tail end of that because
they were kind of facing out all those
dinosaur guys that were holding on the
one place they had left to perform so
anytime a newer younger person would
come in it would just be like lasers of
hate you know like who's this [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's not like funny and you're
like how do you know you just got past
you know give him a chance but they
would want to cuz they were holding on
to the spots you know guys like Barry
diamond didn't Steve Kravitz and Jeff
Altman and don't know any Charles
fleischer yet I mean they're guys that
were like pretty big deals in the
eighties and early nineties maybe they
were like this Sebastian's in the in the
capital is enough of that era but you
know all things as fast as opposed but
your arm but they were big deals back
then you know they were like funny dudes
looking to see in a tons of late-night
appearances but they just like got older
and then that was the only place had
left and then dudes like Sebastian and
Ernst and in and of and burn always guys
were coming in and people like who are
these new guys but as they phased them
out and it was kind of more of us then
it became more of like this you know
fraternity Brotherhood Clubhouse type
thing where we'd all hang out chase
girls around have beers hang out tell
stories and then it became kind of fun
it was still dead like your average
tuesday or wednesday would the show show
is supposed to start at nine wouldn't
start toll there were six people minimum
in the showroom so sometimes I'd work
the cover move to so I would just call
to the manager's office or Mitzi even
you'd have to call her to get the okay
like Mitzi can we cancel the show
because it's 945 and there's only three
people in the audience that was not
uncommon for it is there one that's so
crazy she'd be like Rashad places
doing now you know it's like [ __ ]
sold out on a Tuesday afternoon for the
Tuesday night show how the [ __ ] did that
happen did I I mean it's this weird
perfect storm of like podcasting there's
a comedy boom in general as their
littles the comedy boom is like
overwhelming I mean they're either crazy
I was telling someone when I started
there I woman abominus say there was
tops 150 comedians working in LA in LA
New York la New York like you had Road
guys that you never really knew their
names like the guys that did the road
they were always existed yeah like in LA
in New York there were tops 150 comments
what year did you start uh started in on
my 26th birthday probably like 98 99 and
there were tops [ __ ] 150 I'm a kid
named I could name all the New York
comics I could probably go through a
name every New York Comic right now only
because that's that you I mean there was
there was like eight clubs or six clubs
but you knew everyone I mean to everyone
that worked that scene I mean I worked
the door so I I knew everyone will come
by and i'm also not counting like black
comics probably in New York you bite
double that number almost because it was
a whole Lexi in the 90s to the black
comedy scene was the only comedy scene
like thriving yeah and then all all the
rest of comedy was just like one foot in
the grave yeah you know I gave up [ __ ] I
came out to New York in 99 probably in
99 and I remember going to the improv uh
going to the improbably go to the store
go on the Laugh Factory and I could name
all the comics working okay probably I
could probably go through and you know
Zack Sarah Harland Dane like I mean it
was like now man I looked I was watching
I guess the other night I was watching
your youtube thing with its got like
five hundred thousand views on for the
laugh factory oh yeah and I was like I
don't know one of those people oh and
that whole and they've all got a half a
million views I don't know what of them
I'm like
me neither I was like who the [ __ ] are
these guys I didn't know most of the
people i was on the show with that night
probably it's insane that you would not
know like there's a lot of comics now
it's it's mind-boggling yeah I go to
this I go to went to the store the other
night was Stanhope I'm like you end up
it just seems like no one quit like no
one quit and a lot of people are like
well if I was on twitter i could
probably be a comedian and then there's
those guys we got that's a whole genre
yeah of those people who were just
really funny on Twitter and then got and
then decided to become common now
they're on stage reading tweets yeah and
they go on the stand up now and they'd
in there selling theaters I think you
got and then you got so I'll tell you
this what I think happened yeah so it's
interesting because I feel like I got
you know that um I think it's not what
the dog saw it's a hot Malcolm Gladwell
book oh yeah it is what the no isn't it
something and what the dog saw it's the
whatever the one who's right place right
time yeah ok so i believe i started
comedy at the exact perfect time yeah I
really believe I don't think I'm not
talented and I don't think I'm that good
looking and I've been working my whole
[ __ ] life it's why I literally
sometimes I say was just I just was
there was a small selection me in bag
Tom Segura these are people that I go
yeah I look at their funny i'm not gonna
conclude that me steve byrne um we all
got into this business at a time when
there wasn't that many comics working
and then the headliners so they open up
a bunch of improv right headliners were
like David Spade jay mohr the [ __ ]
jim breuer jim breuer it was all this
SNL it was like one genre Sarah
Silverman yeah probably patent in some
clubs I don't think he was headlining a
lot but like and then banja so much the
nine city tour would be like Portland
Austin San Francisco like the cities
were like he just likes to go yeah yeah
yeah I can why not yeah and and so I
remember going to these clubs and then
being like and like Brian Regan was
still headline in these clubs Dave
Attell yeah
Mitch Hedberg Lewis Black they were the
headliners these are all the [ __ ]
biggest names in comedy by right now and
then what happened is they open up all
these funny bones too and a lot of these
guys just like I don't want to do the
road and there was a veil ability and so
guys I'll just say my name definitely
like I got gifted 15 cities a year just
no money look very low money but I got
an opportunity to headline where a lot
of guys never got the opportunity to do
ours yeah I just stretch their wings
Dane stopped started doing theaters I
mean everyone wanted to do theaters that
was the other thing is that yeah
everyone wanted to get into theaters and
so I look at that now and I go the only
reason I'm in at these clubs cuz 10
years ago they needed people I was cool
number one that's it like I liked
hanging out with the staff I liked I
didn't mind I was broke so I didn't mind
if manager or assistant manager pick me
up the airport I didn't need a car
service if condo is all you had I'd stay
in the condo yeah and so I feel like now
I go I don't know how someone will get
on the road and headline it like it is
almost hard impenetrable yeah like
there's and there's so many guys that go
out to one Netflix special and then and
then and it just ending although they're
in and you're like what and then then
back they go away and a brand new guy
comes in and you're like holy [ __ ] man
yeah everyone's so disposable it really
is and it's like now there's so many
specials that come out even that it's
like a big deal for the six days it's
being promoted and then two weeks later
you forget it ever happened and then
there's another spot yeah that's part of
being an obstacle is the luckiest man in
the world yeah we saw CI is funny as
well
he's mediocre at best yeah if you like
to share if you like a watered down Dave
Attell with a hairy Louie Anderson body
yes yeah nobody the name of his next
special is that but nobody he he did he
got to do the road he got to do his
hours yeah he got into podcasting at the
right time like podcasting he he's also
insightful I'm obviously you know
everyone knows he's my best friend so I
[ __ ] with him a lot but yeah he's uh
right now Tom's won't I'm not you're not
my best friend and so but he got into
podcasting in the right time he's stuck
with his podcast yeah and he got on
netflix before anyone knew what it was
and they were just and there were only a
handful of specials yeah bill burr there
was the [ __ ] great ones and Segura's
yeah just got you so much play and I
think now everyone's like well Sakura
got on netflix and you're like well the
other thing is is there a funny a [ __ ]
right like you know it's it's like it's
like half hours with Danes half hour Jim
Irwin Dane did the is that the movie was
wearing a tank top and then he tore it
off then yeah yeah it's that was just
right time right place got out half hour
aired at a time when they didn't have a
lot of content yeah and they were
[ __ ] airing it non-stop yeah who's
this new young energetic Comedy Central
was blowing up right really it's I so
much of it is right time right place
yeah if you started like when comedy was
that it's like lowest point and then by
the time you get to where it starts to
boom and you have years under your belt
and experience when they're like we got
to fill the club so like as a monster
where's he been and you're like I've
been in the [ __ ] trenches yeah well
no one gave a [ __ ] about comedy it's a
great feeling it's a great feeling when
you go and you go to do like Montreal
and they put you on like a young people
showcase or something yeah and you've
been doing it for 15 years right and you
see these kids that have been doing it
for three yeah and they're like no
shiver and they're shivering and they're
looking at their setlist you're like
right you're looking at setlist like I
haven't looked at a set list in 10 years
all right i'll tell you what joke some
gun it like last night last night we'd
always thing and I ones like so like
have you worked this story out on stage
and I was like no I'm a comedian I can
figure this out like yeah I mean this
whoa oh they're like in my head I'm like
this is what we're doing for a living
yeah I mean I've bounced it around but I
part of the fun of that room is [ __ ]
not knowing what you're saying yeah and
letting it feel genuine if you go up and
look like you do a material you Bob if
you're like reciting it there's no fun
to the story or whatever I got lucky to
I think in the podcasting thing because
people I've had a bunch of really good
stories right when people needed content
yeah and I got plugged in and I got met
up with Rogan called the machine story
and then that like it's that I find all
parts of this business interesting who
and who do you consider in your class
when you started um Ari's in there we
stood he started maybe a year to before
me um who else is around I started um
Aron Kader was around you remember Brian
Keith Etheridge uh who just brought him
up last night I don't know but he's like
a writer-producer now it works like mike
& molly and like all these shows someone
just brought him up last night yeah he
come here cuz he's still kind of around
I mean there's no right guy right thing
I think if i'm not mistaken I think
Bobby Lee told a story about him Oh
probably about yeah yeah I can see that
they were like really good friends back
in the day before the lead to a great
story but um Bobby Bobby wasn't in my
class he was like ahead of me but we
became friends like very early on when I
was doing the open mic at the store yeah
cuz he used to host it and he just saw
me one day and he was like I was just 18
year old [ __ ] pony head imma just
turned 30 for like a week or two ago
damn ya da [ __ ] that's you're in a
you're in a a sanitary supplies in a
sweet spot right now okay I believe it
man I oh I said everyone if I was if I
was ten years younger I'd be a billion
how do you 43 get the [ __ ] out i no no
no I'm 43 I started stand-up or the old
I started at 26 oh yeah that is a prior
years older than the average they say
the average like 22 23 24 sort of 26 and
I feel like I feel like it behooves me
cuz I definitely lived a life yeah and
so I didn't I didn't go up like I
remember and this is no knock on Dana
whatsoever but I remember watching Danes
material and being like God I wish I
could write like that all my stuff was
real [ __ ] I'd done
yeah and I was like Danes like talking
about fantasy stuff like right you know
like it was like his brain just worked
differently than mine same with louie ck
i remember watching louie ck early and i
was like not to draw an obviously a
correlation between their acts as if the
internet hasn't done that a million
times yeah but Louie would do like talk
about fantasy stuff yeah it was an
absurdist yeah and I wished I could have
been like that but I don't have that
brain I was like I'll tell you about the
time I took acid went to Disneyland and
then yeah and I was like because no
one's doing that and in my head I was
like I wish it was so simple now now I'm
like I'm so glad I wasn't doing [ __ ]
other people were doing right but the
time I was like I was like I wish I I
had no litmus to find out of what I was
doing was good yeah cuz he does that
make sense yet is it grass is always
greener look out look too yeah people I
would like the guys that are really good
at writing wish they could be physical
performers and vice versa yeah but then
you just realize that's like a
confidence thing to that comes after
you've been doing it for a few years
you're like I'm really good at these two
or three or four things that I do and
I'm gonna [ __ ] do the [ __ ] out of
them and be undeniable and then ever all
the younger people will look at me and
be like I wish I could tell stories like
Bert I wish I could be an absurdist and
think like oh there was no room for
storytelling in New York yeah like I
mean I remember DC Benny and I started a
storytelling room on Houston and I did
it one night the first night we did it
and I was like oh this is what I should
be doing yeah me I can't do short form
comedy that's we had to write like that
yet they're like I mean it's just like
and I'm not the way I wrote I think I oh
I often would borrow themes or energy or
from other comics yeah like I've I'd be
like oh this is like i did it with the
tell all the time I've copped to this a
million times but like yeah I've I would
watch the way he didn't stand up and I
would just be like so that's half to
write set up punch set up big punch um
yeah da-da-da-da-da-da yeah and that
cadence I got people do with Brody all
the time boho where he's so addictive
that yes you know I go and is the hand
thing that he doesn't eat when he says
it you got it no one
doing what he does oh no one can know I
can every once in while you catch
yourself like doing ab rowdyism or
something like that just because you cuz
he's so fun to watch he hasn't changed
it all had you know that like I mean
when I first started he was in New York
doing like we see this place called
collective unconscious and surf reality
and he hasn't changed one bit I mean his
voice his writings getting better yeah I
mean sometimes when he performs and he
goes off I've seen re and I watched him
to destroy at UCB one night yeah destroy
but his cadence his personality his
voice is he staying authentic to it is
entirely yeah it's Kris I've got a new
movie ten things you like about me I got
10 things i hate about me I've got hair
on my [ __ ] yeah yeah like just [ __ ]
the greatest who did you who did you
like when you first started who really
like the guys you'd love to watch right
or what love to watch work um I like to
what I didn't get to see him a lot but
when i first was starting stanhope would
come to LA a little bit more yeah and I
loved watching that dude because he's
just I mean he's so interesting and like
on edge all the time you know like he
the topics that he tackled in like
long-form it wasn't there weren't one
liners about politics or drinking or sex
and you know there were these long
detailed bits and you when you're when
you're first starting you just can't
even understand how a comedian can do
that you're just like that's so
complicated and it's like a five minute
bit like how the [ __ ] do you make that
funny you know do you remember when you
started and you'd watch people do a bit
about like radio shack you're like [ __ ]
I've been radio shack yeah and I think
about yeah I'm gonna radio shack
tomorrow look man for hearted [ __ ] yeah
how did easy radio shack different than
I saw radios exactly yeah yeah guys like
that were fun to watch um I got to see
Mitch Hedberg once before he died really
at the improv I just randomly was
because I would make it a point to go
every Saturday night is when a lot of
open mics on saturday so I'm like I'm
just gonna go to the improv and watch
watch the guys you'd be there a handful
of times si you been glee when he was
first starting with host it was like bit
back during that and
one night it was Mitch Hedberg was night
he was closing is doing an hour i didn't
even know and i just walked in as a
college Hedberg cool and i was before
the he was the legend and i went in
there and I was just like how I remember
the takeaway was like the joke writings
amazing and how the [ __ ] does he
remember that many jokes in an hour
because I don't do that style of comedy
so in my head I'm like remember 81
liners or probably more iced you know so
funny who knew that emit I used to look
at that and go I would get i would i
would definitely get lost oh yeah if I
was yeah man I don't even know like I
forget to tell jokes all the time like
yeah I like I'm so stream of
consciousness now that I can't imagine
having like like Demetri Martin was the
same way I'd be like how does he
remember that long line up yeah I'd be
like I could [ __ ] I'd be telling
jokes twice oh yeah all getting a whole
section it was this the time when like
Mitch had like painted nails and the
glasses on definitely the glasses by the
nails but he was definitely like the guy
didn't look up once one time yeah so he
was like it was cool to see that rogan
I'd always like to watch just cuz his
style was so conversational but like the
he was so conceptual about the material
you know back when he was talking a lot
about aliens and pyramids and and how
dumb humans are and what if like all the
power went out and like he would just
pay you didn't read a really good job of
painting a picture and just guiding you
through and a lot of it were premises
that weren't really based in reality you
know it was just like what about this
possible future or what about this
possible path of what if aliens did
build the pyramids sir what if all the
power went out I don't know how to build
a battery or do all the stuff and you're
like yeah that's an interesting outlook
and the way he would guide you through
and be funny the entire way I was like
that's how I wanted death like how I
want to do comedy that bill hicks
approach was similar Kinnison we know
where you were just and not necessarily
like angry and railing against the
system which Joe didn't do a lot of but
you're just being conceptual and like
presenting ideas and making those funny
as opposed it just like a series of one
liners which were really popular back
like the mid-2000s really what's the
guy's exact and all those guys and they
did it extremely well but it just wasn't
my thing I loved watching it but I loved
watching it too I didn't I was never
good at it either yeah like I wanted to
be that way but i think is a lot of it
is the way people see you yeah you know
you know who used to do a lot of one I
don't know if he still does but you did
a story last night that destroyed was
Nick thin yeah he transitioned from one
liners two stories and he's [ __ ] so
we did you see beesha together like a
year or so ago and he went up and I'd
seen him in a while and I was like oh I
can't wait to see all his new jokes and
he was just two stories and they were so
[ __ ] great cuz he's a charming
charismatic dude and he's and his pacing
is real right yeah like he really like I
I said to one of them fight and I said
it enough last night but I was like dude
you did a fantastic job yeah his story
was so like you I was really everyone
that was on that show that was just
[ __ ] murders tonight [ __ ] they
have what's his name Brian um the Brian
the biggest comic in the world Brian
Brian something Brian Regan a read no
way he's victori did I men in Denver the
nicest human in the world right I was
opening for Bobby Lee and we're at
comedy works and with the show finishes
were upstairs just talking to the crowd
whatever and then some employee comes up
and he goes cuz we knew he was back
there was in town playing Red Rocks next
night and then he just wanted to come
watch comedy well it does that you know
so he's hanging out and then an employee
comes up and goes hey uh if you're not
busy Brian Regan wants to meet you I'm
like I'm no longer busy like a side of
six people I'm like these people are no
longer here like what do you need it and
then it rings me that is just like
hanging out with like his is road
manager and some other dude and uh and
he goes hi it's a it's a pleasure to
meet you're very funny tonight out my
name is Brion I'm like I know over time
not like an open mic ER again look you
just like it's a pleasure to me you're
really good he was asking me about the
material I was doing and I'm like this
is this really happening right now he's
Kate oh thank you babe it was so cool um
he uh
good I mean it could have enough with
some in the airport the next morning and
he's waving where he does had it for
like home can you be my father you're
the coolest he uh it was the best him
and uh we were in I was in Des Moines
and I got a text from Pete Corey Ali and
he's like be partying tonight and I was
like I wrote back I go you in Des Moines
yeah he's like yeah I'm posting now and
I was like I am now and he was like cool
is it okay if I bring Brian Regan and I
went are you [ __ ] kidding me and so
they came by they came by the Des Moines
funny bone I just got done doing this
Joe they roll up in Brian's tour bus and
[ __ ] just start shooting tequila
drinking beer and I and I like I was
like I was like hey man got to give me
two seconds to geek out on you yeah like
I was like [ __ ] one of my favorite
moments ever is me and my dad would
listen to XM comedy your album came on
and I just was laughing top to bottom
with my dad and it's really cool that I
got to share that with my dad yes we
couldn't listen to a towel or anything
right but like to be able to laugh with
my dad it was really great he was like
like real heartfelt except thank you man
like no man I go oh that's great here
like that's a my like if someone said I
go I was really cool thanks I brush it
off and hung out all night he was like
that's so cool he's the best man he's
the [ __ ] best I listened to him the
other day with my kids yeah I put him on
with my kids my kids were left their
debts off that's good i'm like this
[ __ ] great that's great he's a rare
case man where he's just like been
touring relentlessly for 20-something
years yeah and he's squeaky clean
everyone loves him I've never heard one
bad thing about him ever I never he did
by the way a little footnote that
30-minute live 30 minute comics on
represents the danger he did the same
night really yeah I watched him and Bane
both to theirs Wow yeah and I was like
it's so crazy like I mean I wonder if
there's anyone that did what you always
look at that like those young comedian
specials yeah you're like oh dice Sam
Kinison Roseanne yeah the old Johnson
yes guys smoke cigars like that was
never heard from again yeah I like in in
WWE were like they'll be like the
heavyweight like contenders you know
they have like cool names and
some outfits and then they're fighting
like Bill Bradley and yes some guy with
black shorts losing she followed you
follow wrestling now you soon as younger
open like sorta getting back into it cuz
it's so popular now it's all right it's
weird how is it stinks analogy thing it
stinks that CM Punk is out of it right
when I start watching right yeah cuz
like apparently he was just the most
enigmatic is that the right word
enigmatic um I don't know cuz I don't
know too much about him but it could be
a word like yeah yeah he's just the most
fascinating guy yeah you could do that
yeah and and uh uh and now he's just
retired from wrestling yeah and with no
and then you've never liked he's gonna
join the UFC was a rumor I'm like what
yeah it would be maybe let me tell you
something if he wins oh it's gonna be
great yeah if he could if he could get
to the place where he could win oh that
would be fun to watch cuz I mean like do
you think conor mcgregor's fun dude CM
Punk CM Punk has only been focusing on
the showmanship yeah on the thing we
like conor mcgregor for right you would
make conor mcgregor look like [ __ ]
like a sausage salesman on like a coma
yeah it's all showmanship and character
and stuff and it's coming i I grew up
watching a lot of wrestling so like it's
more fun than the UFC to me because a
lot of UFC fight if you don't like
people that know the moves like always
got him in a darme bar rear naked
reverse whatever I'm like dude I don't
even see that right yeah but to them
it's the most exciting thing and that's
like a minute of the whole fight but
wrestling is over-the-top the at they're
lowering a cage that you can escape from
there's like a straitjacket or doing
moves that like yeah they give you said
it all to you everywhere you can throw a
guy 40 feet off the top of a [ __ ]
ring onto a table oh yeah like if you
I'd be like what's the monthly package I
have to order because I'm watching it
every day if they if they did you have
see in a steel cage yeah and like you
could scrape the person's face that
would it started off as yeah like a no
rules you're probably too young because
when I was 22 23 24 UFC was um tank
Abbott it was an legal you
illegals in anywhere we had a we had
stolen cable so we got every UFC match
ever cool and we just every Satur friday
night we watch him and you just used to
nothing there's no internet like there
was no internet yeah like it was just
like oh this guy's good he's uh he's
jujitsu his guys dad created jujitsu and
you're like what I mean it was uh it was
really fascinating I was at it I I say
this so much lately I don't know why but
like I feel like life experiences have
changed so drastically in just a
ten-year gap of living a life yeah as in
people aren't having life experiences no
no no no maybe maybe that not really
that's how I was thinking but like so
like you're 34 right like do you
remember going to school without the
internet oh yeah for sure okay I'm not
my generation are cuz i'm like i was
born in 82 so I'm like the earliest end
of Millennials so I had your my sister's
age okay so yeah so you are so you
definitely went to college and email was
showing up when you got to college yeah
like some people had internet but it was
like the slow dial-up see but it wasn't
like universal because it was computers
were expensive and internet was so it's
like the families with money and then he
went to their house and then they had
check out this [ __ ] porn but they
would take like four minutes to download
of like a picture it was that that was a
real normal thing back so you must have
been I was all you got your cell phone
uh 18 so the year 2000 okay yeah it yeah
i got mine in i got mine probably 98 99
because we it was like it was considered
a luxury yeah and it was like my parents
were [ __ ] Guinea what do you need a
phone for would your parents do my dad
owns like a marble granite like business
oh really yeah did you everything about
doing that I did when he told me I had
to repeatedly by the whole life until
that's gonna do comedy kidding in the
family business you do every summer we
had to [ __ ] do that [ __ ] we're
carrying sacks of [ __ ] cement and
pallets of [ __ ] I've like marble and
granite
I like late i likey were blue-collar
family they made us learn how to work
and this is what money means and this is
how you earn it two brothers my
brother's in the family business in one
younger brother really say yeah he does
that and then I one of the arts were
like what the [ __ ] what was it like how
did you did you get immediately in the
comedy did you gotta like art school or
no I went right in like I I knew I
wanted to do it from age like 14 really
yeah I saw it on TV at my friend's house
I didn't have cable he did and he's like
dude come over I have all these channels
now and well it was like this new
awesome thing for us and we're flipping
through and he's like I found this show
where there's all these comedians like
these guys just like stand on stage and
are hilarious oh my okay and he flips to
it and it was an auto rerun of evening
at the improv and I'd never heard of the
improv I never knew you could like stand
on stage and do comedy like my parents
have comedy reckons they didn't know
George Carlin when parents first
generation yeah yeah they moved here
from Lebanon really yeah an ad like one
or two or not ATF or so there's gonna
sound silly but like does that mean that
you always had lebanese food oh yeah did
i had it two days ago but they live in
LA I go to their house once a week they
don't they don't like they never made
like french fries and burgers they do
that like some time let they'll make
like they'll mix American food with it
you know really so like my uncle married
a a woman this is many years ago so
she's Mexican and then they started
incorporating like some of their food
with lebanese food so like there's you
could have there's a meat patty called
kefta in in Lebanese food and you can
put it in on kebabs it's like that meat
that using kebabs you could shape it
into a patty so they combine that with
it's served with rice usually so they
combine that with fajitas and made like
this hybrid dish so it's like those meat
patties with rice and then bell peppers
and like spicy sauce [ __ ] it just
[ __ ] that one of the best things I've
ever eaten in my life and it was like
this hybrid dish created so now there's
always that and then there's guacamole
next to hummus and all these other
welcome only belongs
next time for sure I know that I think
about it yeah they're too awesome
dipping submerging that you know what I
had the other day I had um chick pea of
guacamole whoa yeah is that it yeah
chick peak walkable it's just like a
hybrid of the two it was so [ __ ] good
I was in Orlando of all places that's
weird that they would have it there I
know it was st well it's even weirder is
a universal studios that is even weird
yeah don't expect them to take big
swings are ya so it's like Florida never
does anything right and that's like a
really right thing to do as you know
what they had do you know what they had
when I was in high school when I was 18
I remember this so vividly first time I
ever saw stand up ever yeah uh I mean
I'd seen I'd listen to sam kinison on it
with brian callahan in the back of his
bus trip going to ice skating yeah I'd
heard dice you know when I was in high
school but senior year my shut my junior
year uh for New Year's Eve chris Roberts
bill sansoni me and maybe like Cayman
and Alan Reger we all and a bunch of
girls went to a hotel out by busch
gardens yeah like [ __ ] just in the
middle like in the middle of nowhere
tampa for us and got a hotel room and
chris Roberts played Comedy Central all
night long and they had just had huh
they had comic after comic after comic
after comic and I remember thinking the
reboot the idea that if you didn't like
that there's a new joke coming there's a
new comic come in the reboot of it
constantly was so great I think we saw
Bill Hicks on that and my buddies they
were like quoting these guys to me and I
just was like [ __ ] blown away it was
like that's badass it was a new yeah I
didn't know you could do that and so we
watch the show and it's just like that
the the image of a guy on stage being
funny just was like burned into my
cornea I just like couldn't get it out
and I was just like that's such a
fascinating thing and then like a year
later maybe it was in teenage time so
could in like four weeks but like it was
like a wild later i'm watching like a
wedding mt
v and they were doing comedy it was like
MTV summer series when they're always
crazy summer [ __ ] on the beach and then
there was stand up on that show and it
was Jeff Ross before I even knew it was
my first time seeing Jeff Ross and I was
like you can do this at the beach I'm
like I'm in like I gotta do this is what
I got to do with my life dude I there
was a period where I was like I didn't
know if I want to be a stand-up or I
just wanted to be a MTV Veejay yeah
because that life looks so for sure Oh
God until Jessie camp came in and you're
like what's this [ __ ] oh I went in an
audition for that season of wannabe
every day my dad called me up and he
goes they're doing this casting call for
wannabe a VJ down in you would have
killed it's so [ __ ] hard and they
gave it to him and I said I said dad I
saw the business works he was buddy you
don't know how the business [ __ ]
works because you go down on you wait in
line he's like you wait in line in your
audition yeah and he goes you'll learn
something it'll be a good life
experience and I went down I wait in
line I did my I did my audition I did my
audition really well but they didn't
pick me and then and I you know it's so
funny as I didn't tell them that I've
been written up in Rolling Stone
magazine so I was like I want to earn
this on my own yeah and I should have I
really should have that's the thing you
like dave holmes is still working to
this day yeah yes i remember dave holmes
got it and they're like this kid Jesse's
so good I just thought you a video of
Jesse partying with someone the other
day yeah he's making this weird come
back or trying to like he's been popping
up in things yes i'm in the laugh
factory last year really like hanging
out with a couple rock start guys that
were like there for the show and he was
like around here taking pictures with
him and [ __ ] i was like that guy still
cuz you haven't heard anything for 15
years and then I was like hey you know
what the [ __ ] out whatever that is he'd
be an interesting podcast if you get him
to be not on yeah to talk about like his
actual the hard thing with some people
is like is like you don't want them to
like the character I did a podcast some
of the other day Cameron Bure who it was
and I was like I was like oh I hope I
can get this person to just be
themselves ya like it like riff raff
yeah I don't like one of the
I love this show called a hot ones have
you seen it yeah it's um it's all first
we feast youtube channel yeah and it's
just them eating hot wings you eat n hot
wings and they get progressively hotter
are they asking questions but the great
thing is the wings are so hot that
whatever persona you carry with you
disappears because you're going huh like
you're just human you're just human you
can't help it yeah he's river idea riff
raff was like hmmm I have to take my
jacket off he like he lost he longs to
all of it like my identity is alive know
what's funny is that you saw how much of
his identity was true you were like oh
yeah because he is really his accent
like this really accent and butt but
like he stopped rhyming things like that
it was just it was so good yeah and he
was like that's right you should give
guys like marilyn manson in there like
all these we need Eminem I know I
reached out to them and was like hey
just giving you a heads up I would love
to do your show yeah and they reach back
there like key are supposed to do
tomorrow and then I was like and then I
can't exactly i'm going to do saint
louis this weekend and then Doug loves
I'm doing I shouldn't say it Oh exit I'm
doing Doug loves movies tomorrow night
oh nice I bailed on Doug a lot oh yeah
and I feel like that's it's not cool
[ __ ] st. Louis right and he had kind of
booked it around me being there and that
if I just don't show up took his dick
move but um but I told them I said to
the first we feast guys I go I will find
myself to New York to do it he's a film
in New York and like thank you Wow
because they don't pay anything but it's
soap it's so good TJ Miller does it and
and has a spiritual effect on him like
you see him go like into a [ __ ] place
yeah it's it's so good he's a perfect
guy to do that show i told i told key
and Peele do it and i said to I was
talking to uh Eric Abrams last night
like oh I got the best is I go the
lighter one but the heavier one and and
eriko's the heavier ones the darker one
ah and I go oh well that one you're like
don't tell anyone else I don't know
which was which but that one is
hilarious yeah it's just [ __ ] he goes
into a place we going like this that's
such a good show I gotta watch this I
was i it entered that's why I say like I
don't know like do you do much went with
the youtube channel I never did now I
never got it you got it I know you
really have to I really believe that
that I believe it's so easy to make your
own sizzle reels these days yeah like i
like i said this i feel like this is a
generational podcast like when i started
at one of the lucky things about me is
that technology arrived just at the time
i got into the business they can and
came out with this camera called The the
GL to and the xl1 yeah and those cameras
made made shooting television
immediately cheaper like like a hundred
thousand dollars cheaper wow so you
could shoot pilots for nothing so like I
got like someone I remember someone
going like I was telling somebody I'm
sure to probably go how'd you get a
pilot I was like I don't know they
needed it someone yeah they called Manus
yeah can you do and I was like yeah and
so I ended up shooting probably 40
pilots well in my life it sounds like a
lot yeah but it's just because of this
this this camera and then Sony came out
with like an equivalent and and it just
was i was in a group of people that
could make their own content yeah and
and I done some stuff where was like
anything man on the street they're like
want I'm just gonna buy a [ __ ] gl2 i
bought my own gl2 to make my own pilots
yeah by a gl2 and a [ __ ] boom mic yes
she hurt Burt and all a friend and be
like hold this Mike yeah and the
technology now is at a place we're like
I've said this to everyone I'm Bert Inc
my production company this is all my
[ __ ] gear in this right i do a
podcast i do a vlog i bought another
camera it's inside right now without the
camera for the vlog it's uh it's this
it's a canon g7x it's [ __ ] fantastic
real is camera is
like HD video fan tastic i just bought a
camera the other day i wish i had it in
here mom i bought a canon i think is a
sony rather i bought a sony a camcorder
because i want the product that problem
with this camera is the battery done
last lock very long that's like an hour
if that but i want to fill my live shows
want to film every one of my live shows
want to document all my live channel i
call that says I realized in doing this
last hour that that is so [ __ ] handi
to go back and look exactly how a joke
works right and then present it that way
again yeah um visually Kissinger like
wow where was that all watch video
sometimes and I go I was looking down at
the front row yeah when I was saying
this and it like it makes you look like
your eyes are closed you're like how was
I like what were my hand movements or
something yeah and yet it is i mean it's
cheaper than ever to do that [ __ ] and I
get the only thing that's expensive
storing data storing storing like oh
yeah footage files yeah because I end up
buying these these uh lacey is then the
brand name these Lacey external hard
rock hard drives i just put all my shows
on one but but but i mean like i would
be doing if i mean i say if i were you i
should be doing it too sometimes i feel
nerdy cuz i'm like 43 and I'm doing it
I'm doing a vlog but that's sick that's
the nature of the business and haze in
the phrase but that's the nature of the
business it's like it's way more do it
yourself and it's ever been yeah and
like now if you go in to meet with
anyone for anything they want to know
that they're like what have you created
and what are a bunch of finished
products you already have you you need
to have a body of work you need to have
like a list of things you want to do and
then like I'm watching Kimberly congdon
yeah Kimberly congdon i think i'm saying
that right yeah and a girl named Sarah I
think as well they have this uh this
little web series they're doing with a
play two sisters you think I just
watched like four of them I'm not I'm
not saying it's the greatest content in
the world yes great out of the four I
left a handful of times yeah but its
content in my head I'm going I'm going
back to be a show yeah and what they're
doing is they're learning
how to make something funny I I hope I'm
not something I'm [ __ ] on it but it
was like like they're short they're like
a minute 30 and you get a couple laughs
out of it and I go in there learning how
to make content the hardest thing in the
world to do in this business is write
something on paper have them film it and
have it actually be funny oh yeah yeah
gap between there such a big gap yeah an
execution for sure and that's why I
think I feel like I've landed in this
hosted reality space because I can be
funny in front of I can make the people
holding the cameras laughs yeah if you
can make those people laugh then the
people watching or laughing but yeah you
should be doing I mean it's like so much
[ __ ] I wish all things coming in man
maybe I'll talk to Bill and how about
this but I feel like all things comedy
should have a production side where it's
almost like sign up and then you can
shoot some stuff yeah your green screen
exactly and in our offices put a green
screen in there so that we can do our
own the hardest part of having the
access to that equipment to shoot
something I'm doing it I'm gonna call
out right now on the air yeah [ __ ]
yeah the last time I saw I was [ __ ]
hammered which probably is trying to
happen to be my log line for everyone
i'm seeing these data last time I saw
you I was wasted I'm [ __ ] what a
great excuse that have you ever do
anything like ridiculous or dumb I
wouldn't you know what I'll do I'm just
gonna I'm gonna buy the green screen
stuff and I'll just put it in there yeah
and then bring my camera and I'm gonna
shoot a project for all things comedy
with all our talent yeah yeah and I'm
gonna and it's gonna be what's up buddy
you busy I'm in a meet and greet at
digital summit in Atlanta Jesus Christ
what I'm doing a podcast with Nick
Yousef him we were talking about all
things comedy I'll call you later I'll
call you later okay yeah but exciting
should happen with that that's actually
what I was just talking about right now
hold on hold on you're on the podcast
you're on the podcast wait I want you to
help me okay is rolling that's that's
fantastic all right let's talk I'll uh
all right I'll talk to you later on well
that almost became a very litigious call
yeah yeah [ __ ] and here's my biggest
secret of all I was good like yeah how
about al Madrigal is the best yeah Al's
[ __ ] are he's a burned-up artists
work it's like that guy sleeps 40
minutes a night yeah yeah he really does
it's got a family and like multiple
career arcs going at the same time it's
like when does that dude sleep he just
is a bit he just you know man I've seen
him and this I hope this sounds like a
compliment but like I've seen him go out
party get [ __ ] up be up at 6am [ __ ]
emails out [ __ ] oh yeah I got a
meeting at a it's I'm gonna go by
Natasha Leggero a car like [ __ ] like I
think that our chelsea peretti I'm gonna
go by chelsea peretti a car yeah like
just the [ __ ] craziest then takes us
great dad yes his wife is gorgeous yeah
it's super cool yeah yeah and I look at
my shitty life I'm like [ __ ] it did you
get that you got a good life man when I
was like it was pretty [ __ ] I was
waiting to come in I was like this is a
house is a real you live in a home
someone said that to me the other day
and I was like she said you're like you
don't you know most of my friend we all
live in [ __ ] apartments yeah like I
this [ __ ] I went to sport chalet is
closing and they have these having these
crazy sales where which sport Schiller
they're the original one in la kenyatta
sure oh it's G a massive massive
location and they're just getting rid of
everything everything's like sixty
percent off to anything outdoors sports
related is like dirt cheap [ __ ] I'm
running over there and I see a giant
basketball hoop was was he filled water
and you know and I'm looking at him like
I want that right it was like seventy
percent off and I was like I want that
and then I'm like where am I gonna
[ __ ] but it in a driveway to my
apartment building cars are hung the
[ __ ] out of the way in my apartments not
gonna happen on the street so then did I
come here I'm like this is a home like
this where you put a [ __ ] basketball
hoop you could park a car in a driveway
you could like it throw a football
around you can have a [ __ ] man cave
and all the [ __ ] then but then then it's
interesting I liked living an apartment
yeah almost more because
yeah my fear is my fear has always been
like I don't know you especially when
you get older like I keep saying older
I'm not old but like yeah like you look
at like so many guys that didn't make it
yeah or like so many guys that had a
good year and then or had a show and
then they went away and then FN and they
went out and spent the money and then
lost it I've always been like keep it as
low as your paper overhead super [ __ ]
low right like I remember I was looking
guys like like I saw seth green one time
was driving a [ __ ] honda civic yeah
and i was like god damn it that guy's
doing it right yeah like elliot cool no
went to dinner one night and he drove
like the cheapest a bicycle the cheapest
to the Cherokee you could borrow like
the the sport the cherokee sport with no
rims Wow and I just was like and I think
I've always I've always had that
mentality a little bit and I was
terrified to get into this house I was
like like are we at we had a great
apartment I just talked to Danny O'Neill
about this yeah I we've to have an
amazing [ __ ] apartment it was a loft
with 40 foot stories oh cool in
Hollywood overlooked in the Hollywood
Hills nice and it was just gorgeous two
bedroom uh-huh open-air plan like deck
is so great and it was free it's totally
free free yeah my wife worked for the
building so we got it for free [ __ ] yeah
I was like and I was making 1,200 bucks
a week on the road yeah and I was like I
was like this is the deal I'm [ __ ] I
can always make 1,200 bucks you know I
was like I can we can get by we don't
have like great stuff but we have a not
one nice car yeah and and then and then
and then I started work for opportune
time I was like we need to buy a house
because it was and I and this is one of
those things right place right time
right 2008 and my wife's like we need to
buy a house right [ __ ] now oh yeah
when houses are practically free and we
got the house for nothing and but
adversely you walked through it it's
like we've been really slow to add on or
to upgrade it because in my head I just
it's like you I don't I don't want to
get caught with my hand in the cookie
jar yeah
but we're renovating what's great is you
have all the time in the world it's your
house yeah look you don't need to do it
all in a year you could do over a decade
you can book we're gonna add this and
that a second story another man cave on
top of the main content they talked
about that they were like tea would you
do a second story on this we're
renovating spiral staircase that looks
like I'll be so [ __ ] is that a log cabin
it's but this is this is the greatest
thing this is the reason that we won't
leave this house yeah because the the
other thing is I don't know like I don't
there's certain things i don't
understand a business so I'm like okay
so we bought this house for X amount of
dollars Oh actually you can find it
online but like yeah but you can't we've
bought it for X amount of dollars it's
increased by by probably double in price
yeah but right if we sold this for that
price then we can only buy this exact
kind of house again all right that's
what sucks is your life huh Larry a lot
of money in this but what good is that
to us yeah the end up getting a house
it's not as cool as this yeah and so
we're like we'll just add on and yeah
put a master bedroom in and [ __ ] make
the back a little better you like that
kind of thing like I get the the the
fear where you're like can I hold on to
it like am I gonna keep working but I
think that that keeps your ass in gear
it keeps you working you'll never be
content or circulate you get a family
got like a mortgage GF could steve byrne
i think said that a while back when he
was like getting married and having a
kid made me Oh keep work extra hard
because he's like why got a wife and kid
to support so I'm creating a TV show now
you're not gonna get it made let me I
will tell you that is the one thing I
will say is like if you can't if you
can't find that extra oomph to bust your
ass and work twice as hard as you've
ever worked no not after the kid you got
a softer ya know that once you get once
you knock a woman up yeah you're gonna
be successful dude you're you won't be
successful you're gonna be working like
like cuz the second done I'm gonna go
blow a load and a girl it's all day
condom it's just yeah haga Zanna
at her name after yeah what's your name
all right cuz I'm gonna start working
way more and we're gonna have this baby
the UH it's the [ __ ] I mean I look at
my schedule now my schedule is over
[ __ ] whelming it's like we're going
through we're looking at the season
tickets for the Rams yeah and she's like
you need to cancel some of these weekend
so you can come but I I don't work on
Sundays so Joey Diaz law of [ __ ]
stand up comedy dude I just adopted that
like i neva know yeah I gotta talk to
him about this Joey Diaz is up first
thing he said dog you're [ __ ] cutting
your Sundays and I was like why he goes
sunday you need to be home with your
family you need to be home with your
family on sunday yeah you need to be
there have dinner with your family start
your week Monday morning fresh yeah and
that's Joey's sundays are for like yeah
you it's to recenter like I don't have a
family yeah I'm I go visit my family
that like my parents is that that's the
thing i do so great to recenter your
[ __ ] yeah you dislike chill out cuz
you can't this is one of those careers
that is 24 hours a day like this no
break Joey Diaz and Joey Diaz will not
like that i was talking to someone and
they're like yeah we would i wish we
could get you and Joey Diaz to start
doing your Sunday's you guys would make
more money and I was like what they're
like Joey will not budge Joey's selling
out everywhere he goes yeah he will not
budge he's like that's not all he's
working hard as [ __ ] man yeah he's
[ __ ] impressive yeah but yeah I think
it's the truth man as soon as you have a
family like I work I was told my wife I
was like I can't cut these weekends who
do you think we're paying for these
[ __ ] tickets right like I I fly out I
fly out every morning sunday morning at
first crack of dawn to try to make it to
these games yeah this we will see how
that works but um but yeah I want to go
to our rams game oh I you know what I
was saying this is my ID is what I was
one things I want to talk to Alan bill
about but like I was like me al and Bill
and [ __ ] someone else should buy just
cheap seat [ __ ] season tickets for
all things comedy and just let everyone
in the company use them for whenever
they want like you know like just put
them out there and go hey there's a
sign-up list if you want the tickets
it's [ __ ] nose bleed but it'll be a
blast you go to the rams game tailgate
I'll be tailgating every weekend
bill be tailgating yeah you know it's
gonna be you gonna [ __ ] find someone
great tailgating of course I know it's
like and when we were saying it's 300
bucks yeah for [ __ ] season tickets
for she those planes that's so good so
like and then my wife goes why the [ __ ]
would you buy those I go cuz if I was a
young comic and someone said him and you
wanted I when I was young comic someone
say you want to go to lakers game and I
was like uh yeah and they were like well
the tickets aren't the best I go I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm going to a Lakers game
yeah it's about the whole experience
it's about looks like for football
weather looks like let's tailgate let's
bond with a friend you know and have a
good time drink some beers it's all
about it's all about the tailgate yeah
you're only watching half the game
anyway well burns gonna have the best
goddamn tailgates in the world yeah for
sure i can guarantee you yeah that's cuz
he loves this [ __ ] yeah he's just got to
get him to [ __ ] have a TV show in the
city so we can all go to his tailgate I
never guys everyone focus on bill burr's
career for a second yeah yeah I'm
sitting emails into its jus spent a lot
of time watching online um watching like
what just youtubing [ __ ] I'm I I used to
more but I had to get my edit wean
myself off of like just going down the
internet k holes and like and then going
oh [ __ ] it's now four thirty in the
morning dude it's not healthy I talked
to my therapist about it I go it's a
form of addiction for sure like when you
get on facebook and you're just
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling
and scrolling and scrolling and next to
you know you're [ __ ] 13 weeks away
from the day you started scrolling and
you're like you're like oh [ __ ] you got
bit by a spider yeah [ __ ] i'm watching
him lose his leg like I remember once I
was like gonna go meet up with a friend
to like eat dinner get some drinks
whatever and I had like an hour and a
half and I was like all go right for a
little bit and then I sat down on the
couch took my phone out opened facebook
and seventy of the 90 minutes had passed
the next time i looked at the time like
i just opened my phone as a no facebook
and i looked at the top of the screen I
was like I'm gonna be late to dinner
yeah and then I looked at it like how
many times a [ __ ] day two I do that
dude on how many hours a week and then
I'm like how many of those hours could I
spend doing something productive and
then I was like no more no more that's
the way
gotta live it right now snapchats my
addiction yeah i'm i'm starting to get
hooked on cuz i'll give you some really
good ones fat boy ferrari know what's
that Rick Ross Rick Ross DJ Khalid's
prints are following him be pretty so
bizarre yeah it's everything's a key
everything they don't want you to go who
are they like what you keep you want to
talk about going down a [ __ ] k hole
hold on a second yeah this is the guy
you gotta follow hang on I'm gonna find
this so that i can share this with
everyone because this is even better uh
what's his name h3 h3 productions and
he's like he's kind of like collateral
resent dj khaled color oh this guy's so
[ __ ] funny now he does he does um he
does h3 h3 uh he doesn't a reaction
video to DJ khaled that is so [ __ ]
funny DJ it is so [ __ ] funny where is
it [ __ ] my mom I can play this whole
thing but basically he does a reaction
video to DJ Khalid having uh celebrating
holding down just take a look at this
for a little bit he's clearly a
millennial from Brooklyn clearly this is
because he's shooting in what we I
actually called video camera mode that
was like a real thing for me yeah but
90s kamcord it's him watching dj khaled
and being just cynical about you'll see
if i can go big screen
I just love the way this guy talks
I'm getting excited by this music here
guys get me pumped up dude oh wow
hoarding it under a while fulfilling his
gay fantasies taking a frickin giant Bob
would come to his face enjoy this my
friend boo-boo that looked painful oh
god I can't talk he's doing a parody of
himself I just got one way a little bit
I wasn't ready for that look at that
what wheels upset god damn he's got just
one big fold there between his body oh
so bad for that girl it does not look
like she's having a good time she's just
getting freakin pounded dude smart
you're loyal your genius I love you
let's have tender lovemaking my favorite
parts coming up hold on I gotta show you
my favorite part hold on
okay here we go here we go DJ Khaled's
in the shower naked and he's got his
best man the director Evan behind the
camera oh my god don't get was a [ __ ]
boy and shout out to Iowa we just got
the [ __ ] show of a lifetime Holy
Smoke I love this I it's a just watch it
is watching this shits on him and I
ended up washing like five of his videos
and then in my head I'm like so that's
what the point I make to you or where I
go ya like like I'm [ __ ] there's so
much [ __ ] out there you could like
critique like I was like our part of me
wanted to critique a long time ago I
wanted to critique poorly made reality
shows we're and call them out on their
lives cuz there's so much [ __ ] we go
that's not yes I was stage the stage hey
bar rescue how are you getting audio on
the three guys that just walked in off
the street that's impossible that's not
you need to have mics on them someone
had to walk up and go hi my name is John
let me put a mic on this for you kid
shows a two hour process they're
perfectly man i know that it's so my god
drives me nuts like okay so this guy's
signed off on you doing a show about him
smoking pot while working and spitting
in people's food he'll never work again
yeah I'm telling me that that guy signed
off on that right but uh but that like
something like that like just I go like
i was talking to eric Abrams about it
last night and I was like i've said this
i said this a lot i go and this
something travel channel said to me like
[ __ ] six years ago and i don't think
i heard it until now but passion begets
passion so like whatever you're
passionate about if you or what it like
that thing that you like you look at
like Doug getting doug with high it's
such a good series because Doug loves
getting high yeah he loves getting high
and he just loves sitting around and
bullshitting when he smokes pot and
that's why that shows fun he'll never
stop doing it he's passionate about it
he doug loves movies' dog loves is the
should be the predicate or the preface
to whatever the way every comic thinks
what do you love like what do you love
doing and then how can you put it out in
a way where we get to share what you
love
cuz that's a bottomless well if you
actually love something you're
passionate about you're always gonna
want to get up and do it you have new
ideas surrounding it ya Dums built like
an empire off pot cuz he loves pot yeah
and the things around it any what good
at pot I do i do this call in sick to
work show tour that i do where i go in
and do radio at drink on radio gig right
to the club at like 11 or 12 yeah we do
a noon show I really love i love morning
drinking i love it yeah like i love it
and i'll never stop doing these cuz
there's so much [ __ ] fun yeah and
adversely and i don't know if it's
passion begets passion but they're all
if they've sold out everywhere i've ever
gone so like so like i'm sure people are
sharing and passion with me yeah that's
the thing that I go so like like what
like what do you love and how can you
show me what you love like that maybe
that's the way to look at this business
what do you love and how can you show me
what you love because this guy that
loves [ __ ] [ __ ] there are guys
that love [ __ ] on whatever is
working yeah you know on finding the
person that found the niche yeah you
know like and they just want to roll
their eyes at and go oh really that and
then they make fun of it think of how
many people teamed up with with david
cross when he should own Larry the Cable
Guy yeah cuz they were like oh cuz you
know Larry the Cable guy's a fantastic
person yeah and he's a fantastic act
there was a big portion of America that
that didn't rep didn't identify with
yeah they were like [ __ ] this guy yeah
and so they like that's the crazy thing
like like what do you love I love I love
music and I love like style that kind of
stuff yeah um and like food and travel
like all them take great food pictures
on your Instagram x you really do I was
like I literally saw it today and I was
like I kind of want a burrito right
right damn it yeah it's just fun to
don't know why it's just fun to do cuz
it's like everything you can do on
Instagram people can roll their eyes a
we take selfies you take pictures of
food you take pictures of cars but and
then you're like it's a [ __ ] photo
website like or an app like you're gonna
what do you want to take pictures of
things I don't like like these are the
things I enjoy like I love coffee like I
will go to like coffee shops and like
pictures so like I know way too much
about coffee so okay for no reason
besides I really love it but then you
post those pictures some you'll make
money but [ __ ] two days later there
somewhere in Portland doing a gig and oh
hey where the coffee where do I get
coffee where do I get food where do I
get clothes where do I get this what do
i do that i don't like you should you
should ask me [ __ ] i wish i were
you i would do like I'm this just
spitballing but what I think would be
cool cuz I recently have gotten back
into coffee yeah where i'm like like i
started going i stopped ordering just
black coffee and i was like i'm gonna
treat myself yeah like I'm gonna allow
myself to enjoy it because I always felt
like I don't want the calories but then
I was like well [ __ ] it's not that many
calories and its calories that are going
to end up being negative because I like
burning the calories but like what it
would be cool what I what I think would
be cool say you got a vlog and you just
walked in new order to you went you
found the place where you want to get
good coffee maybe good food and they've
got like a nightlife scene where they
have like spoken word or music you get
young artists and you use their music to
drive through your every thing and you
just do it every city you go to ya and
you just shoot it and put it up today
we're going we're in Seattle we're gonna
go to my favorite place in Seattle yeah
we're gonna have coffee we're gonna get
something to eat and we're gonna see
some live music yeah that would be [ __ ]
and that's like and the thing is you
love it yeah so it would be something
where where every week I go oh this is
gonna be good or oh [ __ ] i'm going to
seattle you know what I I would I
wouldn't mind getting in my car like
there's something nice when you go I'm
getting my car to go get a nice cup of
cross oh yeah like it's a it's the
ritual of I love lower making it at home
yeah or driving to the place in like
ordering it and standing there watching
people start their day or let go about
their day like there's just some
comforting thing about it and then it
tastes [ __ ] great yeah is it a
perfect thing to do it's that's I mean I
would love like I would love something
like that I would love to watch it
mostly because you'd be into it you know
yeah but like that's something you could
do and you could put up you could we
could [ __ ] bang out 13 of them and
then I guarantee you some network calls
you up there like hey can we acquire
your material yeah you have
footage can we edit it into a 22-minute
show do you mind if we clump them what
if we sent you out to seattle i mean
would you do that if they said what if I
was like well send you out to seattle
find the best Roasters the best places
to get coffee best place to get like
like I love when you get like like I
went to this one place in Michigan he
was in Michigan and I was on yelp i love
yelp yeah and I and I was like I think I
searched BLT right and they made a BLT
with homemade bread [ __ ] thick bacon
big beefsteak tomatoes and I literally
i'm i wrote a review about this place
well and i wrote a view so aggressively
about how this BLT changed my life yeah
but like I would love there was a guy
used to have a show George something on
travel channel where he just ate burgers
it's called like burger timers nut
burger time it does a video game yeah
that's like a movie yes this is called
fat burger knows called Murder yeah it
was young black guy with dreadlocks and
a fat friend right now I'm doing pretty
good to the US yeah but like I'd love to
see that [ __ ] there's I just believe
that way like you know find the things
you like and and like what would be cool
to see you like with fashion yeah take
apart it backwards so like like I would
love like if you did like a [ __ ] of
research history on skinny jeans yeah
and you're like let's how did we get to
skinny jeans yeah like why did we get
the skin how did it get there though
like like that would be fascinating yeah
you know that would be the history of
this weird style and then or the history
of why jeans are what they are like why
you have skinny jeans well how did acid
watch become popular yeah like that
would be badass totally so I mean that's
a lot of work I'm sure you got a [ __ ]
yes I like a research yes of a tough but
I know a lot about denim like really
that's really it just like I we just
live in an age where you can [ __ ] you're
like I want to know about this and then
you open up your computer and then like
a week later you have all this crazy
knowledge and you can reach out to
people that know a lot about that stuff
and talk to them so you can get like all
kinds of like information
for every right away and then you can
like turn that into like a product if
you want you know because that you have
the resources available like you can go
i'm doing a podcast about this thing or
I want to do a vlog or a web series
about this specific thing and everyone
else can just type that into the search
coffee show you know and it'll pop up
and there's an audience for its so niche
now that you can do a show or a podcast
whatever about a very specific thing and
like there'll be a market for it might
not huge what's the last thing I'm gonna
go look at mine too because mine will
come up what was the last thing you got
that you like laying in bed you're like
I wonder about this and you [ __ ] in
and then you became a mini expert on uh
it was uh i think it was something
ufo-related really yeah i was like what
is it was like the history of like a
certain UFO crash or something that
happened and then i started reading
about like Roswell again and like
certain accounts of like air UFO crashes
in the 50s and [ __ ] and I was just like
I'm not even that interested in this
today but you read a couple articles you
like why didn't know about four hours
later four hours later yeah or is it
conspiracy okay you ready I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you the things that have
interested me within this past weekend
okay okay let's see um Mount Everest
because i'm watching these guys on
snapchat 21,000 28 feet summit Mount
Everest yes that's having it uh cowlicks
okay random yeah cowlick I was like I
wonder what the person who has the most
cowlicks looks like like one if there's
a guy out there this guy like Alec yeah
uh Machine Gun Kelly okay um uh let's
see this is all that that smokey and the
bandit I was looking for smoking in the
Bandit jacket I got obsessed with
smoking the Bandit and I was like I bet
you could buy that jacket right now I
that's cuz someone's got to be still be
making that yeah Skrillex and Justin
Bieber Kevin Hart's brother cataracts
glaucoma lori petty these are
things I've just been well they they
have my safari and man Kevin Hart's
brothers all over this because he came
to my show in DC yeah uh I looked at the
village recording studio in LA because
it's like a famous one yeah and that
it's been here since the sixties
Aerosmith Allman Brothers Beach Boys
Mariah Carey Johnny Cash Ray Charles
Eric Clapton Elvis Costello Bob Dylan
the Eagles Guns and Roses elton john
john lennon Little Richard smashing
pumpkins Weezer all recorded albums
there really yeah and I someone that I'm
like interviewing from my podcast
recorded part of their album they're
like oh I've heard of that before and
then I started reading about that and
the history and how many music and then
I'm like I've got to find a guy who can
get me in there just to walk around yeah
and check it out talk to someone in do
full interview about that place yeah of
a run today that would be fascinating oh
yeah i can now know about the village
recording studio I got obsessed with um
the pi Kappa Alpha rape in 1988 what is
it at Florida State pi kappa alpha is
pike okay and it was like I got obsessed
with uh with the rape the anti-rape
movement in America and when did no
means no show up when to stop when did
advocates start standing up for rape
yeah and then I was like that cuz now
it's like I think feminism has gone such
a such a like literally it's almost like
a like a hair-trigger explosion of like
cat calling and it's like everything's
just blown up and it's like wow and I
was like I bet that you know now we look
at I think a lot to look at feminism and
they're like oh man cat crawling
whatever is [ __ ] doesn't hurt you or
whatever there's a meathead genre of guy
that is the anti-feminism or anti-women
I was like oh I bet that was aggressive
when the no means no campaign started
probably so i looked up now and then i
remember the first time I ever heard
about gang rape was with the pi Kappa
Alpha fraternity of Florida State me and
I was like and I you heard about the
details and then I started going like
wow that's crazy that so those guys are
anonymous now because the internet
wasn't
yo wasn't around to like defend their
lives wonder what the prison for three
years can't find him Wow and it's just
like just there's one article online
that you can find like one or two but
like you can't find details about it
they and like and there's no like
there's no women's advocacy group that
stood up for the poor young lady that
got raped yeah that was just like the
rumor has it she was loose and let's
that's online for reality and you're
like so yeah like I got stuck on that I
thought wonder if my phone cuz that most
of these are all my phone and what if
these come from my phone yeah they're
probably linked like just using safari
yeah yeah they're both like it saves the
tabs your searches for both yeah and so
but like it's is really crazy it's
amazing how many other comics names are
in here like people like Ali Wong Annie
Lederman like just people who I was like
just became familiar with it looks like
I'm google every immediately like oh
yeah you know where they're from you
know like with their specials albums
isn't that so crazy it's just it's great
to have it all all that info but like
you just will burn hours in a day just
looking up stuff and then most of you to
remember two days later yeah cuz the
retention value because you just go what
was I called okay I got it and then you
move on and then you didn't really soak
it in you just immediately got it and I
wonder if it's [ __ ] up my brain
because like i sat down to do a list the
other day i was i said this on stage
also in DC so if your didn't DC big
shocker yes i sat down to do a list the
other day and i went alright i gotta
come and I gotta call Tony yeah I should
write down those five ideas and then I
literally my brain goes I wonder when
skis were invented like just any
whimsical idea you have yeah you now
have the luxury of getting that for me
information immediately yeah and I was
like [ __ ] yeah how long would it take to
walk across America so uh and then you
could do two dollars someone already did
that yeah yeah I started going I wonder
if I could sail from from here to Hawaii
I want if that's doable like let me see
wus guys and you're like those guys have
done there's one guy that did it and
they got like three miles off the coast
of Miami and there they hit a storm yeah
and I think he thought like and then I
watched the whole video of them him and
his brother and his brother's son
surviving the already
and I was like whoa and he knew how to
sales are all right that's off the list
yeah I was like I i I'm i had this
[ __ ] [ __ ] insane idea we are he's
going to uh asia for three months right
to like just [ __ ] get off the grid
huh and I was like three months I think
so it's a while there yet last year yeah
like a month Ari's a different
individual I like he really is I know
you know I'm his friend but like
sometimes I realize just how different
we are as men like or roughly the same
age you're just so [ __ ] different and
I love him to death so I'm I literally
said to myself I wonder if I could find
him in Asia like I wonder if I could
yeah I'd just go there and find him like
I bet I could find him probably like I
almost guarantee i could find them if i
use social media and use the internet oh
yeah if he posts a few pictures you're
narrowing it down to a 20-mile radius
that day yeah and so I was like okay and
then I was like I wonder if I could get
a film crew to come with me and find Ari
and then I was like what's bigger than
that if I i wonder if i could get a film
crew to come with me find Ari and then
take him on two days of like the best
trip he could ever have and then leave
him I was like that be fun his [ __ ] I
would and then I started like on what if
i could find Ari and then set up a bunch
of people to [ __ ] with ari for like for
like two days yeah and give him the most
epic trip you would never forget but it
was all manufactured yeah like just I
was like I could do this Truman Show
type thing right I know I get like three
[ __ ] hot chicks to go to whatever
cyber cafe he's going to to check emails
right right and then I just have them
drop a conversation like we're visiting
from wherever I gotta party I've already
I've already rented a whole [ __ ] boat
I've got the crew I've got it all wired
with cameras yeah and then I go them say
I wish we just find a fourth you know
and then our is you know I'd be like oh
I'm before oh all right I have a boat
and it's just us and we're three Swedish
exchange students yeah who have an
aversion to tops and we want someone to
be on this boat with us for a week in
our black bar I'll draw plans all right
and and then I was like I bet I could
totally and then I'm like this is and
now this is a challenge and then I was
like oh you better run this by I better
run this like baseline by Eric Abrams
and re and just be like she's still
going to Asia yeah last night I was like
picking his brain about Asia right he
was like but yeah like that that beat
the ability to give in to win like that
yeah to literally get pulled off track
and just go into the internet
immediately is [ __ ] insane it really
is I really had to get myself to stop I
did it be aware and go no go [ __ ]
outside go look at the Sun God be go
talk to someone of lunch with a friend
go right go do something productive and
not just search it online cuz it will
never end you're you're not gonna like
finish the internet so I haven't ever in
I mean today I was watching some i'm
literally i'm laying in bed I'm like I
got to get over to my buddy's house yeah
i turn on my phone and it's a prank
video this kid did with his dad yeah and
I'm like laughing and then I scroll more
I just it's ad addiction it's a really
is addiction it's as bad as video games
and alcohol on or yeah for sure and like
what does it thing called 30-second
fights like a Twitter account or
whatever wish you had never said I know
I know I'm in my head I'm like oh this
is way better than watching a 4 minute
video because it's just a quick but then
I watched a t30 second fight videos and
then I was like mad that they were
starting to repeat I'm like what there's
no new ones I wasn't supposed to take a
[ __ ] and I [ __ ] time to kill [ __ ]
Twitter [ __ ] out of it yeah it's before
I'm literally like idea of it I just
stare at the wall do you know what
happened you just took like quicker
shits I'm [ __ ] City I get the squatty
potty now so I sit I sit with the
squatty potty with a with a snuggie on
and an iPad and an iphone i got an
iphone and ipad and i'm i'm doing flip
book on 1 i'm checking [ __ ] snapchat
on the other yeah i mean it is i I
there's gonna be like a whole like new
like set of like back
problems that people have it's called
it's called technic have you ever seen
it I got it from so uh technic it's I've
got it it's uh it's from staring at your
phone like this it goes all through your
shoulders and internet [ __ ] up when
you're standing up like looking down so
the latest post I don't know what I did
with my phone a noun front of a panic
attack um the way you're supposed to
show you the way you're supposed to look
at your phone is like up is is like this
you're supposed to look at it I've
learned this from the Sun mate then it
looks like you're taking a photo it
looks like you're videotaping everyone
so I do it right and the starbucks and
people like excuse me yeah like no not I
learned this in the Sapa leopard like
you're supposed to hold your phone like
this it really does help your neck out
yeah um and then if you order like this
and you're getting older and you're
getting I problems you're holding it
like this it really looks like you're
videotaping yeah yeah yeah that that's
gotta be I mean I bet the cases of a DD
and oh yeah I've always said this you
know this is by the way this is an
uneducated opinion what I'm about to say
so if you have a problem that realize
I'm just having a conversation and I'm
saying an idea and it's not bad it's
just an idea but I started wondering if
autism was part of the progression of
people because quite honestly the all
the this not like severe autism but low
on the spectrum is part of what we are
anyway doesn't like to be [ __ ] with
don't like to be touched doesn't like to
be talked very [ __ ] honest you know
it's like it's by the way I don't I
don't have a degree in anything so I'm
just saying that's based on a couple
guys friends kids I know right and so uh
Priscilla and so you start wondering
like that's way we are anyway everyone's
in their phone you don't need anyone to
shake your hand anymore touching anyone
just saying you wonder if like Pete it
triggers it in people or like when it's
just part of it like well at one points
we didn't need anymore yeah I guess
humans we had a [ __ ] primordial nut
or whatever yeah and then finally it's
just shaved off our tail or our appendix
stuff we don't need I wonder if this is
just a transformation in our brain
that's happened in there like listen man
the world
changing this is how the one day we're
all gonna be like that like like you
don't need to be a gregarious hunter
anymore right i don't like panic attacks
by the way i don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about just to be very clear
but like this to refresh at zero clue
what I'm saying zero clue i'm just
literally shotgun thought but like panic
attacks i believe are based on the fact
that um you needed that trigger when you
were hunting animals in the wild right
and then sometimes that trigger these
are all thoughts i don't know if i'm
right sometimes that triggers leftover
in us so i have like a hunter spirit but
i'm stuck in a gatherers world and so
sometimes getting stuck in traffic and
or on langri I start freaking out cuz my
body's not supposed to be in a plane
yeah but he's not supposed to be in a
fun crowd yeah I'm not supposed to be
waiting in lines my spirit would never
wait in the line yeah so getting online
[ __ ] stirs me up owner that'll happen
to people more because of kind of the
opposite you're you're isolated so much
more now so then when you are in a crowd
or in traffic you're that much quicker
to like lose it yeah because you spend
five six hours a day just in a phone and
a computer alone or around one or two
people or I mean you don't talk to
people really you're texting no one
stopped messaging yeah no one's talking
anybody in anyone's and everyone's on
this this platform where their opinions
matter like you know like you know how
hard by the way once again I don't know
if I'm talking about and if I'm saying
something I've heard on a podcast I
apologize yeah like you know hard it was
to have an opinion like when I was a kid
you had to [ __ ] in Culver City the
[ __ ] this someone just called me from
here the other day we're not answering
it but like you had to like write a
letter to a network oh yeah like when
people really put in complaints for all
in the family or whatever that had some
[ __ ] validity to it they wrote a
[ __ ] letter nowadays I want [ __ ] out
and like find an envelope and a stamp go
to the post office mail it yeah I mean I
think I'm a throwback to when offense
was didn't matter like when I was a kid
if you got offended by something you
just like why can't change it yeah [ __ ]
it or you just like learn to deal with
it I think this somewhere in
middle like right now we're on an
extreme where everything's offensive all
the time and you're like whoa I can't
say or do or think anything I have an
opinion anything and it used to be sort
of the other extreme were like you were
just one guy your voice didn't matter
yeah but I just got to be eventually
we're gonna fall somewhere in the middle
where a lot of people do have a voice
and if something really is like racist
or sexist or whatever enough people will
say something and it will get heard and
a change will be made but it won't be
like a trigger reaction was everyone's
offended cancel it fire them get rid of
it you know to be something in the
middle but it's just it's a little too
much now not everything is the most
offensive thing in the universe I you
know I i think i think it's like I think
it's I think the direct this thing is
going to sound really anti all of our
people's opinion opinion but I think the
direction we're moving in is the right
direction like I remember moving to New
York and being shocked that people
didn't say [ __ ] on stage didn't say
like that they making fun of gays when I
got there was not acceptable and there
were like no we do stand-up in the
village that that's right I don't you
can do like you can do like gay jokes
and you could place I take that back I'm
bill burr said Fagin on stage a bunch
yeah like and so did you know but like
but there was a there was definitely a
line of you had to be respectful of the
community there run you couldn't cross
the line and and and I remember being in
that room being like so funny I remember
one guy went up and he goes who's this
kid from like Staten Island and he's
like he's whatever he said I remembered
so brutally like just it was like so
crystal clear he was like a like a guido
from Staten Island yeah and he said
something and someone said did you say
you live in Chelsea and he goes no I'm
not a Mexican or a [ __ ] and and
everyone went wound he goes guys I'm a
comedian but was so clear that he wasn't
trying to be funny yeah he's just being
himself yeah there's like I'm a comedian
there like there's no joke attached you
just said something hateful yeah and and
what's the matter what time what time is
it now okay okay yeah thanks no I get I
have to be somewhere too so it's kind of
perfect okay yeah yeah um that's what
I've been looking at this thing we've
been on the last the tail end of the
battery the whole time I'm like please
don't die out please don't ya um but uh
hold on I had it I'll tell you this when
i get done um I'll tell you what this
when we get done I had an idea we were
talking about passion begets passion
yeah that I shared with uh with brian
brian baldinger and Eric Abrams and I'm
one of my managers reg and he just
emailed me about it it's the dumbest
idea in the world I think it might be
good yeah I'll tell you I learn okay so
that tells you dry so that you can if
you haven't any ideas how to make it
better okay um yeah I remember that so
clearly and I was watching and I was
like oh so like people can tell the
difference trying to joke and hate cuz i
competed that be offended yeah in the
moment thing that's when like yeah
somebody yell something and you snap out
of your acting go ahead and then the
Mexican or [ __ ] yeah everyone went who
and he goes guys I'm a comedian like no
just cuz you're on stage doesn't mean
you're a comedian yeah not everything
he's not everything you say is a joke
like you're sometimes it's an insight to
your soul I'm gonna comment about
something about adopting pit bulls and
and females on stage and DC and
someone's like oh this has to do with
your wife and I was like it does how can
you tell they're like because I know you
have a big dog and I have a problem with
my wife just lets the dog like she puts
on a leash and she was let the dog go
walk right up to you like what grab to a
stranger yeah watch people get scared as
[ __ ] yeah babe you can't do that and I
talked to my therapist about it he goes
notes because um you know in her life
she's always been a five foot three
female huh and this is one of those
times where she's not scared to walk
down the street like there's no fear
inherent yeah and walking down the
street of a stranger looks at her she's
got a [ __ ] 130-pound beast with you
and that she was like a sick for it so
it's assam yes
she yeah and so he's like you gotta
understand that side of it Owen whoa I'm
so funny that some of the audience
looked at me and was like yeah they
walking about your wife right now it was
like how did you know cuz you didn't
need to say footballs usually difficult
massive but I could talk to you forever
we got to do this again yeah Kevin
coming together we'll do whateva awesome
or i could do you're probably yeah yeah
you do ours that'd be fun yeah I had I
had I think Kevin I did it did it a long
time ago oh yeah but I like doing do
drink I quit how long four years ago
this April second was four years
seriously yeah [ __ ] great d feel
[ __ ] great yeah it's been four years
I don't think about yeah how great be
yeah and also i just put some cigarettes
three and a half months ago that was one
of the best decisions I've ever met yeah
yeah I I mean like it just [ __ ] feels
so good yeah I've been with people
smoking cigarettes last two nights yeah
I think adversely I've been smoking
cigarettes right and I'm my back hurts
my neck was all the time I can't see out
of my left eye oh my [ __ ] left side
of my face though yeah and I crazy I was
with Brant Behrendt greg behrendt last
night he was talking about sobriety and
I'm just hung over his [ __ ] yeah you're
like I'm what do you say and I literally
was like my head I was like there's a
part of my brain that goes Bert listen
to what he's saying and then the other
part of his like or ways Lea walks away
and get a cocktail right and I just was
like I was like I gotta get through
tonight that was my [ __ ] thing huh
but like but I don't really drink this
week's been tough on me yeah with
Stanhope and ari's thing and yeah that's
a lot of parties shank was there I'm
[ __ ] getting bingos their iron
scenery she ran away yeah [ __ ] Lynch
shawcroft was there and I'm like [ __ ]
just getting obliterated but I probably
won't try to easily drink when I'm home
but and that's why I don't go by the
store much right yeah oh yeah cuz then
it's just like it falls apart oh my god
yeah did you have like a bottom when you
quit for the Jews quit not really it was
just more of like an anxiety depression
sort of kind of thing it was just
getting like really hard to just deal
with myself and then that wasn't helping
and I was like I didn't want to wake up
at 35 and be like I'm an alcoholic or
like this turned into a [ __ ] problem
oh you shot a 43
ah that's fine yeah no I know you're
saying I'm glad that I just needed to I
was like I gotta remove this for a while
and I never went to meetings never do
the eighth is just like I gotta not do
this for awhile and then I just three
four or five months just forgot about it
really yeah it's really weird that's
interesting every time I quit drinking
yeah I like I'll stop for like a month
and then it's really hard to get me to
start drinking yeah but the problem I
have is that um I get into a place where
I'm like where it's like an event like I
won't drink for a month and then I go
well New Year's Eve I'll drink on New
Year's Eve my wife want me to drink and
everyone all my friends will be like
come on we got a party bus we're all
going here yeah I should do it I'm like
okay like well there's a party bus fine
and then of course this is my first
night back I go [ __ ] heart is [ __ ]
the paint and then I'm like huh I need
some hair of the dog this morning and
like but like yeah I'm gonna I was
thinking about trying to slow down on
the road that's where it it catches up
with me yeah you have all this time to
kill fans are coming up dude I've I like
I was like if I started charging people
to do a shot with me i bet i could buy
another house from ok guys its twenty
bucks to do a shot with me you like
[ __ ] done right and then you just
[ __ ] you wouldn't be alive to live in
the house that was a problem the shots
anyway uh I [ __ ] doing the shots
anyway I just switched over to fireball
I was like I don't count that as a shot
I was like let's just do fireball butter
balls like the spicy Jaeger yeah I quit
drinking before that was a drink Oh or
before it was at least popular but I
keep seeing me to order fireballs I'm
like what the [ __ ] and no like it's like
this I'm like all rights like spicy
Jaeger I've that did the jager thing
when I was 22 ya llega Red Bulls usual
spot never was too big a fan like I did
it a little bit don't shout it out of
the store oh gee debate the store is
just like it's a pot den now when I
started there it was everyone drank it
was way more fun we [ __ ] partied and
did stupid [ __ ] and it was the best but
now everyone [ __ ] smokes pot that is
not a big drinking culture and it's just
like a lot more boring oh the everyone
just zoned out I'm like guys do
something stupid get a [ __ ] in the
main room don't be an idiot
yeah don't just sit there go work yeah I
I'm pot for me if I if I do happen to do
it I just turned into a giggle machine
yeah that's the funnest part and I and I
don't like the kind of pot that like
that everyone else likes where there's
like I just want to be high as [ __ ]
the highest i can possibly be yeah I
think it looks like a heroine yeah I
just wanna get a little tiny like I did
it someone said this so I'm not sharing
any secrets out of school but I smoked
pot to do the UM Rose battle yeah then I
fell apart laughs yeah I don't think so
find a gentle think I've ever laughed so
hard I ran into someone last night and
he was like I saw you with that and he
goes I couldn't tell if you were joking
or not and I go I couldn't tell if I was
joking or not yeah at one point I had
the mic at someone was walking behind me
and I was rambling on are you taking it
away from me and and but I was just like
they put all that [ __ ] weed out in
front of you oh yeah I'm like a little
snack Oh give it to you is like his
payment yeah you're like oh oh yeah oh
where do we get okay let's wrap this up
and I'll tell you my two thoughts yeah
and so the new album is it's called 1982
yup and it's a pre when does this come
out when you wanted to come out uh
preferably before friday cuz that's an
album comes out for friday yeah I
release it today um so yeah pre-sales
now you can order it now on itunes comes
out friday may 27 and then it'll be on
spotify and wherever else you can hear
music and comedy and all that awesome
yeah yeah i'll release it right now uh
the what was I gonna say if that's by
the way like if you want to wait till
tomorrow that's fine too if it's like no
no I I'd really sit tonight to come out
tomorrow oh you've been perfect yeah
perfect oh yeah um there's been a great
conversation man yeah yeah this is the
reason you do podcast yeah totally it
rum being dead serious yeah for everyone
who's like cuz I gonna restore the
podcast this is the only reason i have
my podcast is so that i can sit down
with you and like and kevin and walk in
and talk to people just get to know
people that you know that you see or you
don't want to have tball I haven't
talked to him and forever the best right
yeah and my no fun he's a great podcast
guest too he really she's no fun rolls
with the punches cook is
like comes up with funny like questions
and ideas and he just he knows a lot
about a lot and he's a great guys the
best he's been on mine like four times
he's the best i can't believe i haven't
had him on and I'm when you text Mel's
like a bleep I haven't had Nick on like
yeah there's so many people I go like we
tried a couple times but it was just you
were busy i was on we're trying to nail
down a couple yards it was yeah it's
just that happens is i did the same
thing with the sklar's we were like what
about this day what about that day and
then they were filming something I was
on the road sometimes it doesn't happen
and then it when it does it does oh my
god i just got the [ __ ] out of me
alright so the album 1982 comes out
friday yes you can pre-order it on
itunes right now right this minute
coastal go to itunes do this do this do
me a favor give me a favor this is very
end of the podcast it's almost over
don't stop right now just hang out for
two seconds I'm gonna told you the best
secret yet there's a really good secret
coming up um go on iTunes yes pre-orders
album subscribe to him in Kevin's
podcast occasionally awesome
occasionally awesome yeah and while
you're at this if you're on iTunes leave
a review yeah rate it total and bang one
out for me too if you haven't done and
and and and check it out go check out
one of the ones with hit with Kevin and
teeb yeah and Nick like what's a really
good one they could go to right now
thats like your favorite podcast you've
done uh we had ed templeton on who's I
Templeton he's like a legendary pro
skater oh shut up he's a big deal yeah
he's super awesome okay I'm we had him
on a couple times as one we talked about
travel cuz him and his wife travel a lot
and but the initial one was him just
telling awesome skate stories from like
the 90s and [ __ ] he also that and he's
the greatest guy he's so cool at
templeton and look that's the first one
yeah I'm gonna download that one the
first of the two that yeah that he did
and that was like four or five months
ago or something like that that's a good
one we do a few or kevin and i recommend
stuff the listeners just because they
like are weird like Kevin's a big art
guy i know a lot about style and music
and and and that kind of [ __ ] so we do
if there's a three volumes of that um
and those are the ones that stand out
now yeah okay awesome sooo good luck on
the element thank i do you and thanks
for doing this yeah thanks for having me
on this I appreciate I hope
someone right now is like doing the same
little vine-swinging of ideas they're
like yeah ed templeton they just go over
and click it and all the sudden they're
like oh wow he partied with jason Ellis
how jason Ellis let's so let's look at
jason Ellis is Rex clicker and now
they're [ __ ] off on nine different
tangents and you probably forgot to go
to iTunes so go to iTunes by the way if
you don't I know if you should get my
album my first albums already on Spotify
and Apple music and I'll get for free
off your website and that yet that's
actual episode of the podcast I just
gave it away for free after the one year
mark yes I just made it an episode for
the subscribers so you can download it
and own it for free or listen to that
one comfortably dumb yeah after a while
the people that bought it bought it and
then it's just a cool thing to do for
fans they were dude there were people
that hit me up immediately they were
like finally was waiting for this to be
free i'm lucky [ __ ] like you
were never gonna buy it again I'll
[ __ ] bucks I know and they don't know
how far that goes man you give out all
this free content you like just give me
some
yes without supper
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you